takes porn you might as well  might as well  but now black's king side pawns come  under fire as well from the white rook  so white is aiming to capture them i  mean it still seems like it's going  white's way but a very strange move  there moving the king i don't understand  that one i guess there was a big threat  white's rook was actually threatening to  check and uh the black rook would have  been vulnerable in some scenarios uh but  okay black is clinging on he's about to  go two pawns down though and the players  were seconds left on the clock  oh this is so difficult  no way prague just blundered into  checkmate in one move  he was winning  what a move unbelievable he trapped his  own king  he was winning that so easily and he did  a round checkmate in one he fell for a  mate in one he self-mated himself there  he had it under control he was a pawn up  two pawns up and he allowed duda to  check mate him